figure it never hurts getting as much
practice as possible solving systems of
linear equations so let's solve this
what don't know what I'm going to do is
I'm going to solve it using an Augmented
matrix and I'm going to put it in row
reduced row echelon form so what's the
Augmented matrix for this system of
equations three unknowns with three
equations so it'll be I'll just have to
do the coefficients so the coefficients
of the X terms or just 1 1 1
coefficients of the Y terms are 1 2 & 3
coefficients of the Z's remember one
three and four one three and four and
let me show that it's augmented and then
they equal three zero three zero and
minus two now I want to get this
augmented matrix into reduced row
echelon form so the first thing I have a
one leading one here that's a pivot
entry let me make everything else in
that column equal to a zero so let me so
I'm not going to change my first row so
I'll just be a 1 a 1 a 1 and then my
dividing line and then I have a 3 now to
make to zero this out let me just
replace the second row with the first
row minus the second row so 1 minus 1 is
0 1 minus 2 is 1 minus 2 actually a
better thing to do because I eventually
want this to be 1 anyway let me replace
this row with this row with the second
row minus the first row instead of the
first row minus the second row I can do
it either way so the first the second
row minus the first row so 1 minus 1 is
0 2 minus 1 is 1 3 minus 1 is 2 and then
0 minus 3 is minus 3 now I want to also
zero this out so let me replace this guy
with this equation minus that equation
so 1 minus 1 is 0 3 minus 1 is 2 4 minus
1 is 3 minus 2 minus
three is minus five fair enough so I got
my pivot entry here I have another pivot
entry here to the right of this one
which is what I want for reduced row
echelon form now I need to target this
entry and that entry and I need to zero
them out so let's do it so we get so I'm
not I'm going to keep my second row the
same my second row zero one two and then
I have a minus 3 and the Augmented part
of it and to zero this guy out what I
can do is I can replace the first row
with the first row minus the second row
so I get 1 minus 0 is 1 1 minus 1
there's a bird outside let me close my
window so where was I
I'm replacing the first row with the
first row minus the second row so 1
minus 0 is 1 1 minus 1 is 0 I don't want
to make it 1 minus 1 is 0 1 minus 2 is
minus 1 and then 3 minus minus 3 so
that's equal to 3 plus 3 so that's equal
to 6
right 1 minus 0 is 1 1 minus 1 is 0
negative 1 and then 3 minus negative 3
that's 6 I always want to make sure I
don't make a careless mistake now let me
get rid of this entry right here let me
zero that out so let me replace the
third row with the third row minus 2
times the second row so we have 0 minus
well 2 times 0 that's just going to be 0
2 minus 2 times 1 that's 2 2 minus 2
that's 0 3 minus 2 times 2 that's 3
minus 4 or minus 1 and then finally
minus 5 minus 2 times minus 3 let me
write that down minus 5 minus 2 times
minus 3 it's -5 - -6 that's minus 5 plus
6 is equal to 1 I really wanted to make
sure I didn't make a careless mistake
there so that is equal to
one so I'm almost done but I'm still not
in reduced row-echelon form this has to
be a positive one in order to get there
it can't be anything other than a one
that's just a style of reduced
row-echelon form and then these guys up
here have to be zeroed out well the easy
thing to do let me just multiply this
equation by minus one so then this
becomes a plus one and then that becomes
a minus one and then I just need to zero
out these two guys up here so let's do
it
so my equation I'm going to keep my
third row the same my third row is now 0
0 1 minus 1 0 0 1 minus 1 and now I want
to zero this guy out so what I can do is
I could set my first row equal to my
first row plus my last row because these
two add up they're going to be equal to
0 so what do I get 1 plus 0 is 1 0 plus
0 is 0 minus 1 plus 1 is 0 6 plus minus
1 is 5 now I want to zero this row out
and to 0 this row out what I can do is
I'll replace it with the middle with the
second row minus 2 times the first row
right so 0 minus 2 times 0 is just 0 1
minus 2 times 0 is just 1 2 minus 2
times 1 is 0 minus 3 minus 2 times
negative 1 let me write that down minus
3 minus 2 times minus 1 don't want to
make a careless mistake so what is that
equal to this is equal to minus 3 minus
minus minus 2 or minus 3 plus 2 which is
equal to minus 1 so that's equal to
minus 1 and now I have my Augmented
matrix in reduced row echelon form
reduced row echelon form my pivot
entries are the only entries in their
columns there each pivot entry in
each successive rows to the right of the
pivot entry before it and actually have
no free variables every column has a
pivot entry so let's take go back from
the Augmented matrix world and kind of
put back our variables there so what do
we get we get X plus 0 y plus 0 Z is
equal to 5 that's that row right there
we get 0 X plus 1 y plus 1 y plus 0 Z is
equal to minus 1
that's that row right there and then
finally we have 0 X plus 0 y plus 1 Z is
equal to minus 1
that's that row right there and just
like that we've actually solved our
system of three equations with three
unknowns that's the solution right there
I just throw it in this way just so you
see the corresponding but obviously I
could have written them closer to their
equal sign so hopefully you found that
vaguely useful